[Musique]
très jeune andrée lachapelle à ce
qu'elle voulait devenir comédienne je
trouvais que même ma vie à moi était
trop courte pour contenir toutes les
villes que j'aurais voulu le faire
c'était pour toucher à toutes sortes de
personnages
à 7 ans elle s'inscrit à ses premiers
cours de diction puis fait du théâtre
amateur
et comme kim énergique des fameux toit
andrée lachapelle fait ses débuts à la
télévision dans les années 50 sa grâce
et son élégance sont tout de suite
remarqué à la même époque elle fait la
rencontre du comédien robert gadois sur
le plateau d'un télé théâtre avec elle
aura ses enfants andrée lachapelle est
prisonnière de son image au la cantonne
dans des rôles de femme fatale névrosé
au bourgeoise pourtant le registre de la
comédienne est bien plus large
elle révèle son grand talent dans des
rôles surprenante où on la voit
complètement transformé le cinéaste et
metteur en scène andré melançon a été
son compagnon vie à partir des années 90
complices ils ont travaillé ensemble au
cinéma et au théâtre
il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai fait
j'ai vu débarquer chez lui la télévision
voir ses cheveux toujours la même
histoire
dans ces conditions certains aujourd'hui
pour moscou
andrée lachapelle quand célimène et le
cardinal la comédienne a reçu de
nombreuses distinctions au cours de sa
carrière elle a également été nommée
chevalier de l'ordre national du québec
pierre moment je savais que je n'étais
pas seule elle s'est investie dans
plusieurs causes humanitaires notamment
amnistie internationale andré vous aurez
fait un discours extraordinaire
il avait le don de la parole je suis
très ému alors merci infiniment merci à
vous tous en ou 2016 son amoureux andré
melançon meurt après un combat contre la
leucémie
la comédienne avouera en avoir été
grandement affectée au point de ne plus
sortir de chez elles pendant trois ans
en 2019
après près de 70 ans de carrière la
grande dame du théâtre et du cinéma
décide de se retirer après avoir été de
la distribution d'un dernier film il
pleuvait des oiseaux de la réalisatrice
louise archambault un rôle à sa mesure
qu'elle prendra comme un cadeau du ciel
sa présence lumineuse à l'écran et au
théâtre nous manquera moi je me suis
jamais prise au sérieux et puis c'est
peut-être ce qui fait l'unanimité parce
que je me suis jamais senti ni meilleur
ni supérieur
les plus belles les plus fines
nathalie chong radio canada montréal